is men with a certain mindset have a
hard time being victims he did not say
that men can't be victim he did
obviously next to him he said do you
know what you said that you feel like
you're saying you said that you'll sit
in the room too of a woman that you feel
like should have yeah yeah not like my
view but the thing is sorry I just feel
like you're very like
you're like narrow-minded about
everything no at all you don't you don't
know me
of course but we're talking about this
as a discussion so you see him in
everyday life I'm completely different
but we're here to talk about this so of
course I'm gonna have a sister called
basically you feel you feel like the
sister code was broken
I can't believe I'm in here with two
women that uh that you know that
wouldn't because what it is I said a lot
of the time women believe that because
you're another woman you're supposed to
see it just the way I see it whereas
whereas whereas us as men you saw I
don't know why you saw these all of us
can disagree we don't necessarily think
that you're not believing us you're
saying you're blind too I understand but
at the same time that I was looking into
this
I feel like you're blind to it yeah
that's fine but that's our opinions
I've never met her in my life never no
we have the same opinion and so did you
react to a story is that how you're here
is that is did she was yeah I said yeah
well there you are so that would make
sense why why you agree with her and and
I don't agree with both of you really
because I have a lot of people on my
look at my comment section there's a lot
of people that disagree yeah but but
that's the thing that's what I'm saying
like you don't know me I'm not someone
to be online but my online argument my
point my point okay okay but my point is
we're two different women and every time
we talk about our beliefs on things you
discount it the feminist who who seems
to think we should believe women but
every time you say every time we say we
believe something you give an excuse me
no no you you say oh it's because you're
young oh it's because you're white oh
it's because that like like you give an
excuse for why we believe it instead of
just but the thing is we're just
different I said to you earlier though
I've seen some of the videos that and
when you've spoke about her certain
things the first thing is fat fat fat
people people are different I am
completely aware that maybe no no first
thing I do I do 16 hours of shows a week
and the first thing I say in every show
is fat no I'm talking about when you're
talking about women you like do you like
to describe them you like to to talk
about that and and whatnot but but what
I'm saying the teachers I I can
appreciate that you have got a different
opinion to me I knew I was coming on
here I knew I weren't going to agree
with you I knew that okay I'm probably
sure that's why he said come on here
because he knew this yeah but at the
same time I I can accept that my my
circumstances my my life has gone in a
completely different direction and we
will never agree so interesting I'm not
saying I'm not saying that what you're
saying is [ __ ] I'm not saying that you
are who you are because you're young
I'll just be interested to see how you
would feel about certain things in
another time I know I'm young but I feel
like
as young as I may be I could have I
could be free so much yeah yeah I mean
and that's the thing you don't know my
story yeah that's what I'm trying to say
is as much as I've been through so much
I don't have the same of course but if
I'm gonna listen to the 20 year old or
I'm gonna listen to the 74 year old
that's had a life of experience
that's what I'm saying to you like no no
I talked to a lot of people you you
don't really you don't know I talk to
her a lot I would say I would argue I
talk to more people
I I would agree I would agree okay I
think for me it's your inability to
understand that your your experiences or
the things you because in my experience
people like you tend to chase certain
narratives because it's like what you
want to hear you want to read something
you want to reaffirm the idea that
everyone is experiencing these kinds of
um these these confirmation bias when
you look at when you look at the data
and it says oh 100 people experience uh
you know that essay in in London and you
realize that like 150 000 people died
from cancer and almost 400 000 people
died from everything else you discount
all that all those other causes of
mortality all those issues and say oh
but a hundred people died in one year
and that's a sign that don't you believe
there's a massive issue
100.
this is what makes me laugh about these
sort of discussions
what do you think every man's like we're
just talking about sit there I never
ever
smaller numbers the right words
sometimes sometimes they're using rare
occasions to justify one second
can I can I just read something so um
just going off of the great thing I this
is a U.S stat I will say not UK
um from 1995 to 2010 the estimated
annual array of female grape or sa
victimization declined from declined 58
from five victimizations per a thousand
females
to 2.1 per thousand
so it's not but isn't it
how do you know yeah I see that I'll
find that what do you mean it's less
supported the thing is okay let's just
take that premise okay like so that
that's that's your argument that there's
more grape and it's not reported how
would you know how would you know it
doesn't happen assume every man is a
predator
so don't flip the question on me sorry
so I know people I know numerous people
that have been raped yeah
let me just get this straight so you're
going off of Word of Mouth no personal
experience who I know so so okay okay
people you know yeah how did you know
were you there
it sounds like this this is a sort of
woman diet no offense to you that you
look at me and think [ __ ] that I look at
you and think [ __ ] that like I don't
know
the question
answer the question no no I wasn't there
sorry I wasn't there I wasn't there so
it's based off of what what they've it's
based off of what they said correct
so your that means you're discounting
anyone and this is convictions
answer my question is it was I there are
you are you basing this opinion off of
what women say
um it's it's more sort of how I see no
not emotion how I see the situation if I
know someone
uh say if I know someone had never had
sex before in their life and wasn't that
way inclined and then got great I would
believe them because from what I've seen
from them they're not like that okay but
it's based off of what women say but but
how would you not believe can you do
yeah of course of course but who would
would you in that situation would you
not what what is okay you keep flipping
them no I'm asking you whatever I'm
saying exactly Askins
so so so I'm just I'm just clarifying so
so your assertion that that it's
underreported is based off of believing
women without evidence 100 okay that's
that's my only point so so then so then
if we follow the logic what can we do in
society
or how do you think society would run if
we believed everybody about wait just
wait if we believed everybody
based on what they said without any
evidence well I I think that's bollocks
but we're not talking about that we're
not talking about everything that'd be
like you saying oh that sound bloke was
racist to me and I say prove it yes
that's exactly what it is that this is
the theme because are you now just
supposed to I feel like this because I'm
just supposed to take what I say
happened or should there be evidence to
also back it up I I completely
understand what you're saying and I
agree I agree it would be a dangerous
world if we could if we could just
believe everything do you see what I
mean please please but please but you're
not you're not getting it but I'm
looking at a bigger picture so I say if
you said to me
um someone's racist or whatnot I I can
appreciate we live in a slightly racist
country so I would kind of uh use my
brain and think you know what because at
the end of the day there's not evidence
for everything so you you're you're kind
of as much as as you're like kind of
saying to me I believe in everyone
um
it's a bit dangerous as well the flip
side to to only credit people with
evidence because evidence there's
there's you can you can watch stuff like
this and you can see whether it's murder
or what and it will be discounting all
evidence
tell you what did you know what happened
to me today go on so Bigfoot
yeah but come on now
believe me
no I've got no evidence I've got no
evidence whatsoever just believe me I
always bollocks now because that's a
you're saying to me about these random
little things to brew my pain what you
just said is absolutely
not saying this but just saying I could
go to someone and say he was racist too
yeah of course you could and because
you're white yeah someone should believe
me no I'm not I'm not saved by this
again this is where it gets twisted I'm
saying from my own personal view I know
people but I know that people have been
great and they haven't reported it so
when it comes to Great statistics in the
same way like we talk about men's
problems and whatnot that male suicide
we know is is higher but women women
commit
more they tried to commit more and they
report it more so if men reported it
more maybe it would be a case of women
trying more do you see what I mean but
in this year if you're not reporting
things but at the same time you can view
male suicide as extremely sad you're
like you're moving the goal post because
you're not listening to a word so she
made a point no no no you keep doing it
no it's not because I think every time
someone brings up a point
I'm saying I could literally come out
here today and say of course you're like
you could I could literally cry okay go
cry to someone say you was racist but
the thing is if someone if someone
believes her because you're white that's
fine I will stand there and I know I've
got people that know me that will back
me and say that I have it fair enough
they weren't there a man could say that
someone I could say you know what I
believe that he's not yeah of course I
know her she's not I know the truth
she's not alone I've known her for 10
years but she knows she's lied but she
knows she's lied about it
no but this but then but again you're
kind of not because I'm saying this is
where those sort of viewpoints come from
Injustice no no but do you understand we
understand how bad it is and that's why
men can just be pinpoint as they've done
how many men that this is the thing
there's people on telly that have been
accused of a rape there's been there's
been people on telly that have been
accused of it there's been there's been
footballers and this whole rhetorical oh
you're doing it again no because this
whole rhetorical it ruins men's lives
it's hard to believe when you're seeing
men go off living living Prof like
profitable lives after that's happened
to them where they were were they were
they prosecuted or were they accused
they were they were accused but this is
what I'm saying okay but see there there
you go again if you've never got the
evidence because it's my word against
theirs okay but yeah this is just this
is just this is just what we're going
back to you just believe women without
evidence and that's and I and these are
I would rather believe a woman and then
and then listen listen and in this case
in this case you don't even know them
yeah yeah so you can't even make the
argument the case you just made where
you said there are footballers that have
that have gotten away with it you're
believing women you don't even know are
you believe in a man not to be a great
person you don't know no no no stop
putting words into my mouth that I did
not say I did not because I was saying
so you're neutral to the situation
I I said to believe the evidence so to
wait until the evidence comes out and if
and if there's no evidence then I would
decide on the fact that it probably
didn't happen or there was not enough
evidence to prosecute I don't or there
was not enough evidence to prosecute but
I don't know I was not there why would I
make an assumption on something that I
was not there for that that's fine not
you but this is what I'm saying that
it's it's not a thing that if if you
want to believe that that's that's fine
I I personally don't believe that and I
understand when it comes to this there's
such a fine line because how are you
getting that evidence bear in mind there
was uh like there was a thing up until
because is that no can I just say
something that if I was if I was
brutally graped and you studied and I
went to the police and then you started
digging into my sexual history and found
out that I liked being I liked rough sex
that goes against me but yet that was
consensual so even that that that rule
has only changed recently that would
make sense but no it doesn't of course
it doesn't yeah if someone has an
Evidence of certain Behavior patterns
yeah so I see but again like this is
what I'm saying we just we just believe
different things and that's fine and and
why why would she want them to be able
to prosecute someone without evidence
because certain things never have any
evidence okay so that's really so you
think they should process
I see what you're saying but if it meant
like how are you gonna how are you gonna
tell me now then if I if a man doesn't
inside me or there's no DNA or say there
is the enable there's no much tell me
what evidence you would need to believe
it
typically if you you're fighting yeah if
you're getting in grapes so typically I
would imagine there's Cuts there's
there's there's like like bruises that
sort of thing but do you know why do I
not I I don't because I'm not there and
I don't make assumptions based off of
gender I don't I don't believe people
can I use an analogy right well because
you're saying basically you believe
we're women right
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait that's what you said
you're basically are saying be a
believer woman right and as a and I tell
you what that's scary for me as a as a
black male yeah yeah no hang on I'm just
gonna say I'm scared for me as a black
male because I don't know if you know
the case of Emmett Till yeah of course
right okay where a woman said that he
yeah
right and they were living at a time
sorry essayed
um to some degree or even wolf whistled
or whatever it was right and because she
was a woman and like you say oh she was
a white woman yeah yeah she was believed
yeah right and that boy I know Bruce Lee
because of her yeah now you're telling
me right generally believable women as
if women can't lie so like I said I'm
looking at it yo the standpoint you're
looking at it from is a woman's
standpoint I'm looking at it from a
man's standpoint yeah like I said if men
get accused of something yeah it can
ruin our whole life and this is why
Pearl is talking about it has to be
evidenced based it does it's not saying
that you that it never happened that's
not no one's saying that it never
happened I think that's I think I think
no but listen but listen No but listen
no one's saying it never happened we're
saying if it did happen there has to be
some kind of proof that it actually did
happen and if it didn't
there's cases where there is evidence
and it still gets discounted I this is
what I'm saying this is what I'm going
back to no no no it's not but then I
I'll go back to what I said to you the
bottom line is I would rather believe a
liar than the rapist and and then that's
it that's it I rather believe it I I'm
not a Believer like I would rather wake
up one morning and find out the person I
believe but
is is capable of that as opposed to a
man capable right I think that's easier
to say when you're not the one in their
shoes
so this women will assassinate a man's
character and spread lies about him
because women can be spiteful a hundred
percent
and so I personally I'm not just gonna
give women that power to destroy a man's
character reputation right job
opportunities College opportunities just
because a woman is a woman that's stupid
yeah she felt a certain way but at the
same time it makes me sad to think of
all um the the women out there that
didn't have the evidence that didn't
they got for an alcohol that we can look
at statistics in in sort of that cool
and how much it goes against them yeah
of course but that's for that it's not
no but then I don't want to like go in
there do you do you think it's better to
be innocent until proven guilty or
guilty till proven innocent it is that's
a tough one because I think I think
money and power pick one has no that's
what I'm saying I can't yeah you can't
have a perfect world pick one no no no I
I I don't know how to answer that
because what's fairer what's fairer
what's what's more fair well of course
the the fairer were of the two is um
with with evidence of course that no no
you mean innocent until proven yeah
that's what I'm saying that's the third
but this is why I don't want to answer
this question because even though I can
see it so do you want to live in a fair
Society or on earth oh [ __ ] you're
you're doing this again when you're kind
of like throwing questions at me you're
not really listening to kind of what I
was trying to get out right we've been
listening no no but I'm saying I'm not I
would I don't want to pick one or two
because I don't agree with either
because I think disprove your point no
no it's because if you've got money and
you've got power you can get up with
everything you ever need to be right if
you've got money and you've got a power
if you've got money and power you can
get away with everything if you have
money and power you get away with
everything a lot there's like there's
this there's a chef that's got a
restaurant in London and Parks outside
there every day even though there's no
parking Zone and he just gets a ticket
every day because he can get away with
it because he's got money we okay I
think there's a difference between
tickets
then why is R Kelly in jail how long did
that take I was in school when that sex
tape came out with him graping with him
doing whatever he'd done to that okay
okay what happened at the end how long
did it take what happened
how many how many women I don't know how
many women weren't believed what
happened at the end of the day how long
did he go to jail how long did he go to
yeah of course yeah you know he went to
jail we all know that but how long did
that take how many that video that video
I went to call and it got it got thrown
out okay okay is he in jail now
yes how many women did he hurt after
that first video because it's innocent
until proven guilty he had the video
because it's innocent did anyone know
that I I don't I don't I don't know I'm
telling you say no I'm telling you I
don't know but I'm saying at the end of
the day is he not in jail because if if
you said he could your your claim your
claim was that he could get that people
with money in power can go through
Harvey Weinstein Jeff Webster okay where
are they now how long did it take
sometimes just why do you keep answering
questions what's the point whether it's
relevant or not they go they go down
how often how often do people go
discredible you watch those documents
you have a need to be right you watch
those documentaries there was countless
women not believe because there weren't
any yeah to be right on every single
thing because I'm here to discuss
something else
you're trying to listen even when you're
wrong it doesn't surprise me that it's
coming from this I I've had this
numerous times and fair enough that yeah
I I know I can I can talk loud and I can
be outspoken but I know full world that
what I'm saying is not it's true but
it's true to me but you don't need you
don't know me at all that oh this is
what I was saying I weren't ever looking
at you when I said to you earlier about
that predator and what not that I've got
respect for men I have however just in
terms of like the world view and that
when we talk about oh they built this
world we should be we should be thankful
I I don't look at that I don't think
it's a nice place
yeah because you don't have a respect
for men
as many of you
have you just ban
attack and to monetize
in this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible